let's kick things off with a quiz
suppose I take a normal distribution
with this familiar bell curve shape and
I have a random variable X that's drawn
from that distribution
so what you're looking at right now are
repeated samples of that random variable
and as a quick reminder the way that you
interpret this curve what the function
actually means is that if you want the
probability that your sample Falls
within a given range of values say the
probability that it ends up between
negative 1 and 2 well that would equal
the area under this curve in that range
of values that's what the curve actually
means I'll also pull up a second random
variable also following a normal
distribution but maybe this time a
little more spread out a slightly bigger
standard deviation and here's the quiz
for you if you repeatedly sample both of
these variables and at each iteration
you add up the two results well then
that sum behaves like its own random
variable and the question is what
distribution describes that sum that
you're looking at
think about it for a little moment maybe
you have a guess maybe you think I don't
know it's another normal distribution or
something with a different shape
needless to say guessing is not enough
the real quiz is to be able to explain
why you get the answer that you do in
this case if you have that deep to your
bones visceral level of understanding
for why the answer is what it is you'll
be a long way towards understanding why
normal distributions serve the special
function that they do in probability
zooming out though this is actually
meant to be a much more General lesson
about how you add two different random
variables regardless of their
distribution not necessarily just the
normally distributed ones
this amounts to a special operation that
you apply to the distributions
underlying those variables the operation
has a special name it's called a
convolution and the primary thing you
and I will do today is motivate and
build up two distinct ways to visualize
what a convolution looks like for
continuous functions and then to talk
about how these two different
visualizations can each be helpful in
different ways with a special focus on
the central limit theorem
after we do the general lesson I want to
return to the opening quiz and offer an
unusually satisfying way to answer it
as a quick side note regular viewers
among you might know there's already a
video about convolutions on this channel
but that one had a pretty different
Focus we were only doing the discrete
case and I wanted to show not just
probability but the ways that it comes
up in a wide variety of contexts
I'm in a slightly awkward spot because
it doesn't really make sense for that to
be a prerequisite to this video but I
think the best way to warm up today is
to cover essentially one of the same
examples used in that video so if you
are coming straight from that one you
can probably skip safely ahead otherwise
let's Dive Right In
for this opening quiz question each of
the random variables can take on a value
in a continuous infinite range of values
all possible real numbers it'll be a lot
easier if we warm up in a setting that's
more discrete and finite like maybe
rolling a pair of weighted dice
here the animation you're looking at is
simulating two weighted Dice and you can
probably tell what's going on but just
to spell it out explicitly the blue dye
is following a distribution that seems
to be biased towards lower values the
red dye has a distinct distribution and
then repeatedly sampling from each one
and recording the sum of the two values
at each iteration repeating samples like
this many many different times can give
you a heuristic sense of the final
distribution but our real task today is
to compute that distribution precisely
what is the precise probability of
rolling a two or a three or a four or
five on and on for all possibilities
it's not too hard a question I'd
actually encourage you to pause and try
working it out for yourself
the main goal in this warm-up section
will be to walk through two distinct
ways that you could visualize the
underlying computation
for example one way you could start to
think about it is that there are 36
distinct possible outcomes and we could
organize those outcomes in a little 6x6
grid now if I was to ask you what is the
probability of seeing any one of these
specific outcomes say the probability of
seeing a blue four and a red two what
would you say we might say should be the
probability of that blue 4 multiplied by
the probability of the red 2. and that
would be correct assuming that the die
rolls are independent from each other
you might say that's kind of pedantic of
course the die rolls should be
independent from each other but it's a
point worth emphasizing because
everything that we're going to do from
here moving forward from this simple
example all the way up to the central
limit theorem assumes that the random
variables are independent in the real
world you want to keep a sharp eye out
for if this assumption actually holds
now what I'm going to do is take this
grid of all possible outcomes but start
filling it in with some numbers maybe
we'll put the numbers for all the
probabilities of the blue die down on
the bottom all the probabilities for the
red die over here on the left and then
we will fill in the grid where the
probability for every outcome inside the
grid looks like some product between one
number from the blue distribution and
one number from the red distribution
another way to think about it is we're
basically constructing a multiplication
table to be a little more visual about
all of this we could plot each one of
these probabilities as the height of a
bar above the square in this sort of
three-dimensional plot in some sense
this three-dimensional plot carries all
the data that we would need to know
about rolling a pair of dice
and so the question is how do we extract
the thing that we want to know the
probabilities for various different sums
well if you highlight all of the
outcomes with a certain sum say a sum of
six notice how all of those end up on a
certain diagonal same deal if I
highlight all the pairs where the sum is
seven they sit along a different
diagonal so to compute the probability
of each possible sum what you do is you
add together all of the entries that sit
on one of these diagonals
pulling up the 3D plot we can better
foreshadow where we'll go with this
later by saying that the distribution of
possible sums looks like combining all
of the heights of this plot along one of
these diagonal slices
it's as if we've taken this full
distribution for all possible outcomes
and we've kind of collapsed it along one
of the directions
and admittedly I'm just having a bit of
fun with the animations at this point
it's not like if you are working this
out with pencil and paper you would be
drawing some three-dimensional plot but
it's fun when you collapse it on this
direction you actually do get the same
distribution which I knew you should but
it's still fun to see also even though
all of this might just seem a little bit
playful or even unnecessarily
complicated I can promise you this
intuition about diagonal slices will
come back to us later for a genuinely
satisfying proof but staying focused on
the simple dice case a little bit longer
here's the second way that we could
think about it take that bottom
distribution and flip it around
horizontally so that the dye values
increase as you go from right to left
why do this you might ask well notice
now which of the pairs of dice values
line up with each other
as it's positioned right now we have one
and six two and five three and four and
so on it is all of the pairs of values
that add up to seven so if you want to
think about the probability of rolling a
seven a way to hold that computation in
your mind is to take all of the pairs of
probabilities that line up with each
other multiply together those pairs and
then add up all of the results
some of you might like to think of this
as a kind of dot product
but the operation as a whole is not just
one dot product but many if we were to
slide that bottom distribution a little
more to the left so in this case it
looks like the dye values which line up
are one and four two and three three and
two four and one in other words all the
ones that add up to a five well now if
we take the dot product we multiply the
pairs of probabilities that line up and
add them together that would give us the
total probability of rolling a five in
general from this point of view
Computing the full distribution for the
sum looks like sliding that bottom
distribution into various different
positions and Computing this dot product
along the way
it is precisely the same operation as
the diagonal slices we were looking at
earlier they're just two different ways
to visualize the same underlying
operation foreign
[Music]
and however you choose to visualize it
this operation that takes in two
different distributions and spits out a
new one describing the sum of the
relevant random variables is called a
convolution and we often denote it with
this asterisk really the way you want to
think about it especially as we set up
for the continuous case is to think of
it as combining two different functions
and spitting out a new function
for example in this case maybe I give
the function for the first distribution
the name p sub X this would be a
function that takes in a possible value
for the die like a three and it spits
out the corresponding probability
similarly let's let P sub y be the
function for our second distribution and
P sub X Plus y be the function
describing the distribution for the sum
in the lingo what you would say is that
P sub X Plus Y is equal to a convolution
between P sub X and P sub y and what I
want you to think about now is what the
formula for this operation should look
like you've seen two different ways to
visualize it but how do we actually
write it down in symbols to get your
bearings maybe it's helpful to write
down a specific example like the case of
plugging in a 4 where you add up over
all the different pairwise products
corresponding to pairs of inputs that
add up to a four
and more generally here's how it might
look this new function takes as an input
a possible sum for your random variables
which I'll call S and what it outputs
looks like a sum over a bunch of pairs
of values for X and Y except the usual
way it's written is not to write with X
and Y but instead we just focus on one
of those variables in this case X
letting it range over all of its
possible values which here just means
going from 1 all the way up to six and
instead of writing y you write s minus X
essentially whatever the number has to
be to make sure the sum is s
now the astute among you might notice a
slightly weird Quirk with the formula as
it's written for example if you plug in
a given value like s equals 4 and you
unpack the sum letting X range over all
the possible values going from 1 up to
six then sometimes that corresponding y
value drops below the domain of what
we've explicitly defined for example you
plug in 0 and negative 1 and negative
two
it's not actually that big a deal
essentially you would just say all of
these values are zero so all these later
terms don't get counted and that should
kind of make sense what is the
probability that the red dyed rolls to
become a negative one well it's zero
that is an impossible outcome
as a Next Step let's turn our attention
towards continuous distributions where
your random variable can take on values
anywhere in an infinite Continuum like
all possible real numbers maybe you're
doing weather modeling and trying to
predict the temperature tomorrow at noon
or if you're doing some Financial
projections or maybe you're modeling the
typical wait times before a bus arrives
there are all sorts of things where you
need to handle continuity in all the
graphs that we draw the x value still
represents a possible number that the
random variable can take on but the
interpretation of the y-axis is a little
bit different because no longer does
this represent probability instead the
thing that we're graphing is what's
called probability density this is
something we've talked about before so
you know the deal essentially the
probability that a sample of your
variable Falls within a given range
looks like the area under the curve in
that range the function describing this
curve is commonly called a probability
density function a common enough phrase
that it's frequently just given the
abbreviation PDF and so the proper way
to write all of this down would be to
say that the probability that your
sample Falls within a given range looks
like the integral of your PDF the
probability density function in that
range
as a general rule of thumb any time that
you see a sum in the discrete case you
would use an integral in the continuous
case
so let's think about what that means for
our main example let's say we have two
different random variables but this time
each one will follow a continuous
distribution and we want to understand
their sum and the new distribution that
describes that sum
you can probably already guess what the
formula will be just by analogy remember
in the formula that we just wrote down
where P sub X is the function for the
first variable and P sub y is the
function for the second variable the
convolution between them the thing
describing a sum of those variables
itself looks like a sum where we combine
a bunch of pairwise products the
expression in the continuous case really
does look 100 analogous it's just that
we swap out that sum for an integral
sometimes when students see this
definition of a convolution out of
context it can seem a little
intimidating hopefully the analogy is
enough to make it clear but the
continuous nature really does give it a
different flavor and it's worth taking a
couple minutes to Think Through what it
means on its own terms and so I put
together a little interactive demo that
helps unpack each part of the expression
and what it's really saying for example
the first term in this integral is f of
x which represents the density function
for the first of the two random
variables and in this case I'm choosing
this one sort of wedge-shaped function
for that distribution but it could be
anything
similarly G represents the density
function for the second random variable
for which I'm choosing this sort of
double lump shaped distribution and in
the same way that earlier we went over
all possible pairs of dice values with a
given sum the way you want to think
about this integral is that what it
wants to do is iterate over all possible
pairs of values X and Y that are
constrained to a given sum s we don't
really have great notation for doing
that symmetrically so instead the way we
commonly write it down gives this
artificial emphasis to one of the
variables in this case X where we let
that value X range over all possible
real numbers negative Infinity up to
infinity and the thing we plug into the
function G is s minus X essentially
whatever it has to be to make sure that
this sum is constrained to be s
so for the demo instead of graphing G
directly I want to graph G of s minus X
and you might ask yourself what does
that look like
well if you plug in Negative X as the
input that has the effect of flipping
around the graph horizontally and then
if we throw in this parameter s treat it
as some kind of constant that has the
effect of Shifting the graph either left
or right depending on if s is positive
or negative in the demo s is a parameter
that I'll just grab and shift around a
little bit the real fun comes from
graphing the entire contents of the
integral the product between these two
graphs this is analogous to the list of
pairwise products that we saw earlier
but in this case instead of adding up
all of those pairwise products we want
to integrate them together which you
would interpret as the area underneath
this product graph as I shift around
this value of s the shape of that
product graph changes and so does the
corresponding area
keep in mind for all three graphs on the
left the input is X and the number s is
just a parameter but for the final graph
on the right for the resulting
convolution itself this number s is the
input to that function and the
corresponding output is whatever the
area of the lower left graph is whatever
the integral between this combination of
f and g turns out to be
here it might be helpful if we do a
simple example say where each of our two
random variables follows a uniform
distribution between the values negative
one-half and positive one-half
so what that looks like is that our
density functions each have this kind of
top hat shape where the graph equals one
for all inputs between negative one-half
and positive one-half and it equals zero
everywhere else the question as always
is what should the distribution for the
sum look like well let me show you how
it looks inside our demo
in this case the product between the two
graphs has a really easy interpretation
it is one wherever the graphs overlap
with each other but zero everywhere else
so if I slide this parameter s far
enough to the left that our top graphs
don't overlap at all then the product
graph is zero everywhere and that's a
way of saying this is an impossible sum
to achieve
that should make sense each of the two
variables can only get as low as
negative one-half so the sum could never
get below negative one
as I start to slide s to the right and
the graphs overlap with each other the
area increases linearly until the graphs
overlap entirely and it reaches a
maximum
and then after that point it starts to
decrease linearly again which means that
the distribution for the sum takes on
this kind of wedge shape
and I imagine this actually feels
somewhat familiar for anyone who's
thought about a pair of dice that is
unweighted Dice there if you add up two
different uniformly distributed
variables then the distribution for the
sum has a certain wedge shape
probabilities increase until they max
out at a 7 and then they decrease back
down again
where this gets a lot more fun is If
instead of asking for a sum of two
uniformly distributed variables I ask
you what it looks like if we add up
three different uniformly distributed
variables at first you might say I don't
know we need some new way to visualize
combining three things instead of two
but really what you can do here is think
about the sum of the first two as their
own variable which we just figured out
follows this wedge-shaped distribution
and then take a convolution between that
and the top hat function pulling up the
demo here's what that would look like
once again what makes the top hat
function really nice is that multiplying
by it sort of has the effect of
filtering out values from the top graph
the product on the bottom looks just
like a copy of the top graph but limited
to a certain window
again as I slide this around left and
right and the area gets bigger and
smaller the result maxes out in the
middle but tapers out to either side
except this time it does so more
smoothly it's kind of like we're taking
a moving average of that top left graph
actually it's more than just kind of
this literally is a moving average of
the top left graph
one thing you might think to do is take
this even further the way we started was
combining two top hat functions and we
got this wedge then we replaced the
first function with that wedge and then
when we took the convolution we got this
smoother shape describing a sum of three
distinct uniform variables
but we could just repeat swap that out
for the top function and then convolve
that with the flat rectangular function
and whatever result we see should
describe a sum of four uniformly
distributed random variables
any of you who watched the video about
the central limit theorem should know
what to expect as we repeat this process
over and over the shape looks more and
more like a bell curve or to be more
precise at each iteration we should
rescale the x-axis to make sure that the
standard deviation is one because the
dominant effect of this repeated
convolution the kind of repeated moving
average process is to flatten out the
function over time so in the limit it
just flattens out towards zero but
rescaling is a way of saying yeah yeah I
know that it gets flatter but what's the
actual shape underlying it all
the statement of the central limit
theorem one of the coolest facts from
probability is that you could have
started with essentially any
distribution and this still would have
been true that as you take repeated
convolutions like this representing
bigger and bigger sums of a given random
variable then the distribution
describing that sum which might start
off looking very different from a normal
distribution over time Smooths out more
and more until it gets arbitrarily close
to a normal distribution it's as if a
bell curve is in some loose manner of
speaking the smoothest possible
distribution an attractive fixed point
in the space of all possible functions
as we apply this process of repeated
smoothing through the convolution
naturally you might wonder why normal
distributions why this function and not
some other one
there's a very good answer and I think
the most fun way to show the answer is
in the light of the last visualization
that will show for convolutions
remember how in the discrete case the
first of our two visualizations involved
forming this kind of multiplication
table showing the probabilities for all
possible outcomes and adding up along
the diagonals
you've probably guessed it by now but
our last step is to generalize this to
the continuous case
and it is beautiful but you have to be a
little bit careful
pulling up the same two functions we had
before f of x and G of Y what in this
case would be analogous to the grid of
possible pairs that we were looking at
earlier
well in this case each of the variables
can take on any real number so we want
to think about all possible pairs of
real numbers and the X Y plane comes to
mind
every Point corresponds to a possible
outcome when we sample from both
distributions
now the probability of any one of these
outcomes X Y or rather the probability
density around that point will look like
f of x times G of Y again assuming that
the two are independent so a natural
thing to do is to graph this function f
of x times G of Y as a two variable
function which would give something that
looks like a surface above the X Y plane
notice in this example how if we look at
it from one angle where we see the X
values changing it has the shape of our
first graph but if we look at it from
another angle emphasizing the change in
the y direction it takes on the shape of
our second graph this three-dimensional
graph encodes all of the information we
need it shows all the probability
densities for every possible outcome
and if you want to limit your view just
to those outcomes where X Plus Y is
constrained to be a given sum what that
looks like is limiting our View to a
diagonal slice specifically a slice over
the line X Plus y equals some constant
all of the possible probability
densities for the outcome subject to
this constraint look sort of like a
slice under this graph and as we change
around what specific sum we're
constraining to it shifts around which
specific diagonal slice we're looking at
now what you might predict is that the
way to combine all of the probability
densities along one of these slices the
way to integrate them together can be
interpreted as the area under this curve
which is a slice of the surface
and that is almost correct there's a
subtle detail regarding a factor of the
square root of 2 that we need to talk
about but up to a constant Factor the
areas of these slices give us the values
of the convolution
in fact all of these slices that we're
looking at are precisely the same as the
product graph that we were looking at
earlier
here to emphasize this point let me pull
up both visualizations side by side and
I'm going to slowly decrease the value
of s which on the left means we're
looking at different slices and on the
right means we're shifting around the
modified graph of G
notice how at all points the shape of
the graph on the bottom right the
product between the functions looks
exactly the same as the shape of the
diagonal slice
and this should make sense they are two
distinct ways to visualize the same
thing it sounds like a lot when we put
it into words but what we're looking at
are all the possible products between
outputs of the functions corresponding
to pairs of inputs that have a given sum
again it's kind of a mouthful but I
think you see what I'm saying and we now
have two different ways to see it
[Music]
the nice thing about the diagonal slice
visualization is that it makes it much
more clear that it's a symmetric
operation it's much more obvious that f
convolved with G is the same thing as G
convolved with f
technically the diagonal slices are not
exactly the same shape they've actually
been stretched out by a factor of the
square root of two the basic reason is
that if you imagine taking some small
step along one of these lines where X
Plus y equals a constant then the change
in your x value the Delta X here is not
the same thing as the length of that
step that step is actually longer by a
factor of the square root of two I will
leave a note up on the screen for the
calculus enthusiasts among you who want
to pause and Ponder the but the upshot
is very simply that the outputs of our
convolution are technically not quite
the areas of these diagonal slices you
have to divide those areas by a square
root of two
stepping back from all of this for a
moment I just think this is so beautiful
we started with such a simple question
or at least such a seemingly simple
question how do you add up two random
variables and what we end up with is
this very intricate operation for
combining two different functions
we have at least two very pretty ways to
understand it but still some of you
might be raising your hands and saying
pretty pictures are all well and good
but do they actually help you calculate
something for example I still have not
answered the opening quiz question about
adding two normally distributed random
variables
well the ordinary way that you would
approach this kind of question if it
showed up on a homework or something
like that is that you would plug in the
formula for a normal distribution into
the definition of a convolution the
integral that we've been describing here
and in that case the visualizations
would really just be there to clarify
what the expression is saying but they
sit in the back seat in this case the
integral is not prohibitively difficult
there are analytical methods but for
this example I want to show you a more
fun method where the visualizations
specifically the diagonal slices will
play a much more front and center role
in the proof itself
I think many of you may actually enjoy
taking a moment to predict how this will
look for yourself think about what this
3D graph would look like in the case of
two normal distributions and what
properties that it has that you might be
able to take advantage of
and it is for sure easiest if you start
with the case where both distributions
have the same standard deviation
whenever you want the details and to see
how the answer fits into the central
limit theorem come join me in the next
video
[Music]
thank you